Speaker 1: we should really find a way to help
incels those who are involuntarily celibate.
And we should do it in a way that does not
include forcing women to have sex with them,
which has actually been suggested by some. David,
what on earth are you talking about? So let's back
it up. Incel is short for involuntarily celibate,
and it's more than just being involuntarily
celibate. Meaning you'd like to be sexually
active, but you're unable to find a partner.
It also has a sort of entire subculture, and
unfortunately there have been elements of Incel
that have been interwoven with mass shooters in
some cases which have not gone unnoticed. And more
broadly, there is a concern, and I believe
it is a warranted concern that in general,
it's not just mass shootings. There is broader
anti-social rather than pro-social behavior that
emanates from this group that is in many cases,
disaffected, in many cases depressed. Using that
as a colloquial term, not necessarily clinical
depression, but just dissatisfied and sad about
the status of their lives, etc.. And I believe we
need to find a way to help these folks, including
to find healthier role models than the people that
they often end up worshiping, folks like Jordan
Peterson and Andrew Tate. So we have to consider
the circumstances first. You've got a group that,
among other grievances with society, they're
upset. They can't find a romantic partner.
There's loneliness, there's isolation, the
suffering of rejection in many cases. And
the reason that it would be important to find a
very specific way to help this group of people
is not just that if we can improve someone's
life, it's a great thing to do. But there's
this self-fulfilling prophecy that happens often
within the Incel community, where it's bad for
society not to help them. The very isolation and
rejection, etc., that they suffer leads them to
the path where they find negative role models like
Jordan Peterson and Andrew Tate, and then they end
up blaming everyone else for their misery instead
of maybe looking more at themselves and changing
themselves. And they end up adopting some of
the worst traits of the people that they follow.
It's not just Jordan Peterson and Andrew Tate.
There's all sorts of like charisma coaches and
pick up artists and all this different stuff,
and it makes them even less desirable to the
very people they are trying to appeal to. So
we've got to figure out how to do something.
Incels are often portrayed in a negative light
in society as well, and we know of individuals
within the Incel community that have embraced
hateful ideologies. Sometimes the anger at the
world and for heterosexual incels the anger at
the women that won't give them the time of day
grows into a hateful ideology that includes other
groups of people as well. And then sometimes
it even leads to violent real world actions. So
number one, it's important to understand that for
the vast majority of incels, that's not actually
the path. They're not they're not going to become
violent. That's not what we're talking about.
They're just folks struggling with isolation.
Sometimes it's self-esteem, difficulty forming,
romantic and sexual relationships. We should
give them compassion and support rather than
judging and condemning them, as so many people
do on the Internet. So the question is, how can
society help incels what can actually be done?
It's all pretty. I don't want to say milquetoast
stuff, but what I mean is nothing's going to be
particularly titillating. I think we all really
kind of know what needs to be done. The resources
and support need to be there for people who
are struggling with either body image or
self-esteem issues that become this feedback loop
because of their difficulty. Finding a partner.
We have to establish systems of support for
them that aren't belittling or condescending.
We should encourage people to seek out therapy
or counseling to try to work through the issues
that are underlying what often is a pretty
severe social anxiety, either primary or as
a result of their lack of success forming these
relationships. Lack of self-confidence. Sometimes
there's past traumas or a particularly acute
event where they were rejected by someone which
now has a sort of subsequent feedback loop and
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy. All of that
stuff may need to sort of be worked through.
And so you've got to offer education. You have
to think about what resources can be established
to really think about how do you navigate dating,
how do you navigate relationships? How do
you can you relate to whoever it is that
you consider to be in your dating pool based on
your sexual orientation, communication skills,
understanding boundaries in some cases, helping
people connect with not only others like them,
struggling with the same thing, but also with
those that they would like to be building
relationships with. It could be online. It
could be in-person. We're not really doing this,
and it sort of does fall under the umbrella of we
need to fund mental health. The right loves to say
this problem is mental health. That problem is
mental health. Anything gun or violence related
is definitely mental health. And then, given the
opportunity, they often opt not to properly fund
dealing with the mental health components.
So we need to do that here. And again,
it's I know that it's very popular to kind
of just like make fun of incels or whatever,
you know, it just just kind of like ridicule it
or see it as not really a serious problem. It's
it's a real serious problem in society because
it is a perpetuating mechanism, a feedback loop
for anti-social behavior that sometimes
sometimes grows into actual violent acts.
Send me your thoughts about
as specifically as possible
what can and should be done to support these folks
to hopefully allow them to improve their lives